it's good to keep this I like oh she's
nice well I guess we met over a decade
ago we've been dating for about five
meters Diana we just got engaged about
three months ago please is my engagement
watch just over two years we've known
each other for probably like ten and we
just moved in together a week ago yeah
big changes yes so my husband was
supposed to be here but his schedule
change at the last time now I'm gonna
take advantage of his absence to ask the
real questions I never have never done
it before his sister's boyfriend read my
tarot cards was very emotional I
actually ran away and took a nap and
didn't get much of what what's going on
but it's so very much entrenched in my
culture all right well let's see what
the cards have to say okay we're gonna
pull three of these cards with your left
hand and we'll put them face down right
here I see dogs and this one looks like
that's a good sign oh my god you guys
your first car that this makes me so
happy I bought my card that means like
there's no more love for either of you
like this is it all right okay we
started with the part that means I win
right everything for you guys is about
building the relationship but it's
showing me a move which might just be I
don't know do you live together yes yeah
yeah where we have to move we're
probably moving we have
this is a real thing in terms of your
relationship it reads oh there's no more
big heartbreak like she's gone through
they have to sometimes like work through
things but there's like not it doesn't
show me like destruction oh this is
about babies I mean about children is
about having kids of water having
children are like getting another dog
maybe there's someone who's been making
like a little difficult for you and like
a woman oh and I think that's enough
like it would not harass me it just
reads like there's something about it
where maybe there's some jealousy or
something and how you move through this
is going to like put you at a better
place do you have a trip plan together
we're gonna India oh this is my soulmate
car and looks like the little kids know
it's a pretty cool this is great oh my
god I hope it's like positive I really
do better yeah
career our relationship our trip to
India tarot card reading in general I
honestly am shocked to my core
yeah yeah I have a good way you know
like this was like therapeutic in ways
I've ever imagined according to the
cards were doing pretty well yeah that's
great that's good sighs no I don't I
feel great
[Music]